Speaker 1: And speaking, by the way, of Jim
Jordan, Weaponizing the weaponization committee.
It was revealed this week that Jim Jordan has
sent letters to multiple different colleges and
universities across the country demanding all of
the information about their efforts to research
disinformation in American politics. According to
the letter that Jim Jordan sent to these colleges,
he said, quote, Certain third parties,
including organizations like yours,
may have played a role in this censorship
regime by advising on so-called misinformation.
So he's going after colleges now. He already
failed. And going after Twitter. I mean,
we all remember Matt Taibbi coming
in there and testifying and then
it didn't go so well. And if you've
been paying attention to the most
recent drama between Taibbi and Musk, that
relationship has had a horrible falling
out. But Jim Jordan so far has come up with
nothing with this weaponization committee.
So he is grasping at straws now. Remember when
he brought in those FBI so-called whistleblowers?
That all turned out to be extremist Trump
supporters who actually hated the FBI. So they
weren't actually whistleblowers. They were just
mad at the agency because they didn't like it.
And then they delivered no explosive bombshells in
their testimony. And it was revealed, of course,
that a couple of them had actually gotten some
money from Cash Patel, one of Donald Trump's
close allies from his group. Yeah, it was a whole
big mess and it made Jim Jordan look very stupid.
Just like the Twitter files hearing made him look
very stupid. So now he's going after colleges.
He's saying, how dare you, How dare you research
misinformation? And then how dare you, I suspect,
give that information to social media
companies or the Biden administration.
Now, the thing is, based on the letter, Jim,
Jordan doesn't even know that that happened.
Jim Jordan is just making these wild accusations
against colleges, saying I think you probably may
have could have at some point thought about
possibly thinking about doing these things.
That's the basis for this investigation, folks.
The problem is, even though these colleges have
nothing to hide, they also don't want to
have to spend time hiring lawyers, you know,
sending their people down to Washington,
D.C. to go and testify, wasting man hours,
going through all of their research, compiling
it in a way that Congress can actually read.
That takes time and money. Something that a lot of
colleges don't necessarily have a lot of on hand,
especially for something like this. So according
to some of the researchers at these colleges.
They're already worried that this
is going to have a chilling effect
on their efforts to combat misinformation in
the United States ahead of the 2024 election.
Multiple sources who spoke to ProPublica
about this story say that they are worried
that colleges, rather than have to live under
congressional scrutiny, will simply scrap the
programs or scale them back to the point
where they become completely ineffective.
And that's the goal. That's what Jim Jordan wants.
That's what Republicans want. They don't want
colleges and universities, you know, smart people
looking at the amount of misinformation flowing
all day, every day on social media. Because
what is that going to point fingers back to?
It's not going to point fingers back to this show.
It's not going to point fingers back to my show.
It's not going to point fingers at Sam Ceder
or any of the other folks who do this. Jesse
Dallimore No, it's not going to come after us.
It's going to come after you're you're Charlie
Kirk's and you're Candace Owens and your Fox
News is in your Daily Wire's Daily Caller's
Daily morons, whatever it is. Those are the ones
that are going to get flagged for misinformation.
Because those are the ones that are filled with
misinformation, with disinformation, with lies
of omission. If you've spent any time. Watching
conservative media, reading conservative outlets,
you quickly begin to realize as a rational person,
there are some things missing here.
There's some context missing. There's
a quote that you've taken and distorted that
is commonplace in a lot of conservative media.
Sometimes they just outright make things up and
they never get held accountable. Right. We're
not seeing slander, libel and defamation lawsuits
filed left and right against these organizations.
We should, but we don't.
So the only weapon we have are these institutions
that are actively investigating misinformation and
calling it out and reporting on it. And Jim Jordan
knows that. And he also knows we're heading into
a contentious 2024 election cycle. He doesn't
want people hyper focused on the lies coming
from the right. So he's trying to have this
chilling effect on this research through his
requests to these colleges. That is the point of
it. That is the goal. That is what he wants to do.
And some folks at the colleges are already
admitting it's probably going to work.
Look, I am Farron Cousins. You can follow me on
YouTube at YouTube.com, slash the Ring of Fire.
Also YouTube.com slash. Fair and balanced.
I am on Twitter, Facebook, Instagram and
TikTok at Fair and Balanced. This is the David
Pakman show. And we'll be right back with more.